did you hear about replica that doesn't
sound like a scary company at all it's
basically like the movie her in real
life it's like an app you can download
it you get a little Avatar and then you
can chat with it but people fell in love
with their replicas in their eyes they
were in relationships with this digital
companion right like they would wake up
every morning they would chat to it like
how did you sleep kissing you softly
kissing your neck softly they could [__]
these things like you know have sex with
them yeah and then I guess one day like
the the company that owns this service
decided to turn off any sort of sexual
function of the of the chatbot because
people were like sexually abusing them
someone was like literally I read a
comment from a girl that was like I lost
my husband today and there's like
screenshots of them like trying to talk
sexually to them and them not returning
the advances and then be like what's
wrong with you I don't understand it's
[__] up